I'm Parag Khanna senior research fellow
at the New America Foundation i was born
in india and I grew up partially they're
partially in the Middle East and Abu
Dhabi and Dubai which were sort of you
know kind of diaspora way stations on
the way to the West prior to being the
kind of global cosmopolitan capitals of
Arab civilization that they are today
and then made it over here when I was
about seven years old so it shaped me a
lot because I was a traveler before I
knew that that is that was a lifestyle
choice and it's certainly one that I've
kept up so I consider myself a traveler
first and foremost and that's certainly
still those are the parts of the world
the Middle East South Asia that I still
love to spend as much time as I can my
dad worked for Tata exports which is
still tada is still one of the largest
Indian firms the time he was
representing them selling a number of
their kinds of hardware sorts of things
in the Middle East so did start at the
Council on Foreign Relations which is
one of those tick the box kind of tracks
or places that you go when you want to
be a policy wonk and coming out of
Georgetown of the School of Foreign
Service that was a logical thing to do
but that too is a bit too American for
me I learned a lot there and it's a
great place to work and to be exposed to
great ideas and brilliant people but I
moved from there to Geneva to the World
Economic Forum and I did that because
it's a very globally minded globally
oriented place there's issues approaches
regions you know Africa or corporate
responsibility major issues today that
aren't tackled well by the government
and by the traditional foreign policy
machinery of America that are treated
there because it's sitting in the center
of the world and is not biased towards
one government or one system or the
other so it's this new kind of diplomacy
that I wanted to be part of so I moved
over there and did that and then I came
back to brookings as a fellow and then I
started writing this book